ではダンマパダの5番目の経典を説明いたします
ナヒヴェーレーナヴェーラーニサッマンティーダクダーチャナンアヴェーレーナチャサッマンティーエーサダンモーサナンテノという偈なんです
で もう一度テキスト入って
テキストなくて ナヒヴェーレーナヴェーラーニサッマンティーダクダーチャナンアヴェーレーナチャサッマンティーエーサダンモーサナンテノ
それは一応覚えておいた方がよろしい
大変簡単な偈だと思います
で まずこのストーリーがございまして
すごい古いストーリーで
あまりにも変に感じるストーリーですからね
それはまずその通りで言いたいんです
ある人が自分の父親が亡くなるんですね
父親が亡くなったら その人が家の畑やらね
財産を守って 普通に生活している
生活しながら母親の面倒を見ていると
それでお母さんが あんたは早くお嫁にお嫁をもらいなさいと
この息子をいろいろ責めるんですね
若い人 若者で ちゃんと仕事をして
親を母親を大事にしているんだからね
母親が心配して もう早くも結婚させてあげないとということで
インドの場合は この親の最後の仕事っていうのは
やっぱり結婚のことなんですね
やっぱり結婚してあげるまで親は責任持ってるんですね
子供には ですから 結婚相手もだいたいは親が言って調べて選ぶんです
子供たちっていうのは
あんまりもうどちらでも親に逆らうことはないんだから
女の子の場合も男の場合も
親が選んだ人とは一緒になるんです
今もインドではその風習はあるんですね
ですから この父親に聞いたら
聞いたら もうお母さんはいつ知り合ったんですか？と
結婚式の日だよと 初めて会ったの
そういう風にあるのはごく普通なんです
結婚式の日で初めて会って
それで夫婦として一生生活するんです
離婚はしない それで 100%うまくいくということはないんだから
世の中で何でも 100 でうまくいくということはないんですけど
しかし 今よりはうまくいっているということは確かなんですね
自分で相手を選ぶよりは
親が選んだ方がうまくいく可能性が多いんです
それでこのお母さんも
もうあんたはもうお嫁さんもらいなさいということで
それで アンマ マー エーワン
ワデータ アハン ヤーワジーワン
トゥンメー パティジャッギッサーマイって
それで男の人はもう嫌ですよと
私はもう一生懸命お母さんの面倒見るんだから
そんなもう誰か来る必要はないんだよと
でお母さんもね 田んぼの仕事やら他の仕事やらそれしながら料理やら洗濯
何でもあんたにできるわけないと親が何回も言うんですね
それで息子もどうしようもない
いつでも母親が結婚しなさい
結婚しなさい言うんだから
もう黙ってたんです 黙ってたところで
彼女がお母さんが家に行って女の人を探すんですね
それでお母さんが自分が知っている
女の人がいる家にまあまあ
その話に行こうとすると
息子があんたはどこに行くんでしょうかと先に聞くんですってね
私はなんとか何とかの家にまあ言って
その娘さんのことをまあ話してみたいんだと言っても
娘とは大体話しません
話すのは両親と どうですかと
あなたの娘さんは家の息子にというふうに
まあ両親同士で話すのであって
本人はあまり話しません
そういう家に行くんだよと言ったら
この男の人はまあ一応見たことがあるんでしょう
その女の人はね ですから
まあその家ではなくてというふうに言うんですね
言ったら だったらどこですかと言ったら
自分で他の家を言うんですね
まあまあ 他の家 あの家に行ったらどうでしょうかと
言って話聞いたらと言ったら
お母さんもやっぱりまあどうしても結婚したがらない息子だから
まあ息子に気に入っている女の人はいるみたいということで
まあ何のことなくその家に行って話してみるんですね
それでも話はうまくいって
まあ両親は賛成して じゃあ結婚しましょうということに結婚式を挙げる
結婚したんですけど その女の人はやっぱりあれ
何と言いますか まあ子供がないんですね
まあ子供を産めない やっぱり自分で選んだらなんとかどこかで問題があるという（笑）ということかな
それを言いたがっているか分かりませんですけど
それでまたお母さんの出番が出て
お母さんがまああなたはね
自分好きな女の人と結婚したんだけど
もう彼女は子供を産まないでしょうにと
子供がいないと家が潰れますよと
ですから まあこれ困りますと
もう一人と結婚しなきゃダメですよと 2
番目のお奥さんももらわなくてはいけないんだと
彼があまりそれでも2番目のお奥さんがもらうこともあまり好きじゃないんですけどね
で 断るんですよ もう一人で十分ですからね
2人は要りませんと その話はもう息子と母親がもう話したり断られたりするのは
この奥さんが聞くんですね
聞いて彼女は考えるんですね
で プッターナマ マータ ピトンナン ワチャナン アティック カミ トン ネサッコンティ
息子っていうのは母親の話には断れないんだと
まあ母親父親が何か言うと
まあ息子っていうのはもう聞くものやと
あまり反対 わがままは言わないということなんですね
ですから 今は断っていても
どんどん母親がね 2番目のお奥さんもらいなさい
もらいなさいと 家が潰れるのではないかと
もうもうずっと言い続けちゃうと
息子はやっぱりまあその気になるんだよと
[背景音楽]そうすると
この人がもう一人 二番目の奥さんもらったら
どうせ子供を産める女の人を連れてくるでしょうと
そうすると子供が産んだら
その人が家の一番目の奥さんになっちゃいますから
跡継ぎ作りましたからね
私がなんかよそ者になってしまいますと
今の自分の一番目の立場がなくなるんだと
なくなって そこら辺に何か食べて
家の仕事をしながら もうもうなんか召使いみたいな感じになってしまいますと
そこで彼女はこう考えるんですね
では私が行って適当な女の人を探しましょうと
言って お母さんではなくて奥さんが行くんです
で 行って 他の家に行って
まあ話をつける どうですか？うちの旦那と結婚すればどうですかと
言うと みんなも何言うんですかと
あんた結婚してるんではないかと言ったら
実は問題があるんだと
私には子供がないんだと
子供がないんだから 家はもう潰れますよと
そういうわけで もう一人の奥さんが 二番目の奥さんも必要になるんだよと
ですから まぁ 二番目の奥さんになっても
もし息子が生まれたら
もう家の あの 何て言いますか
この財産のね まぁ責任者になるんではないかと
あなたの娘は いわゆる家の一番目の奥さんになるんではないかと
ですから まぁそんな心配する必要はないんだと
今は 二番目ですけど 子供産んだらもう一番目になりますよということで
彼女が女の人を連れてきて
もう家に入れるんです
お母さんではないんです
連れてはきたんだけど
その女の人はもうこう考えるんですね
しかし これからこの女がもし男か女か子供を産んだならば
もうそれからはみんなサーッとそちらに行ってしまうと
跡継ぎが生まれたんだから
そうすると私はよそ者に必ずなるんだよと
ですから 結婚はさせたんだけど
子供は産めないようにしなくちゃいけないんだと
と企むんです まぁ企んでもそれは言わないで
すごく親切な声であんた妊娠でもしたら
私の責任だからね 私が連れてきたんだからね
ちゃんと私に言ってくださいよと
すごい親切な顔で ものすごいもう全面的に面倒を見る
二番目の奥さんの  二番目の女の人も姉みたいな感じで
一生懸命何でも面倒見てくれるんだから
そういう分信頼しているんです
自分が結婚しているのに
私まで連れてきて それを私の方何から何まで面倒を見てくれるんではないかと
そこで彼女は妊娠する
二番目の女の人も人は妊娠する
妊娠したら まあまあ この自分の姉みたいにね
いつでも面倒見ている一番目の奥さんに
まあなんか妊娠したみたいですよと言うんですね
言ったら まあ彼女はその日から一生懸命面倒を見る
ちゃんとまあ料理を作って
まあまあ これ食べなさい
あれ食べなさいとか いろいろ体にいいものは作って作って持ってくる
で まあまあ彼女も一生懸命妊娠したんだから心配しているんだということで
持ってくる食べ物はもう感謝しながら食べると
で 彼女が何のことなく食べ物に薬を入れちゃうんですね
薬を入れるということもわからないんだから
で 流産しちゃうんですね
毒を飲んでしまって 子供が流産してしまう
それで まあそれでまた時間経つと
またもうまた妊娠する
二回目に 一回目流産しちゃったし
二回目も同じことで流産妊娠したんだからと話を聞いて
一番目の奥さんがまた一生懸命面倒を見る
何から何までもう何もさせないで
自分でもう朝も昼も夜もいつでもご飯作って
いろいろ料理を作って食べさせたりする
それで二番目の子供流産してしまうんですね
死んでしまっちゃうんですね
で そういうことで 二回も流産したんだから
やっぱり彼女の親戚やらね
これは何でしょうかとか考えたりして
で 調べたらやっぱりこの
まあ彼女は分からないんだから
彼女に叱るんです お前バカではないかと
どう考えたっても 一番目の奥さんはあんた子供産むことは好きになるわけじゃないんだと
あんた子供を産んじゃったら
あんたの家は家の財産があなたのものになるんだからね
一番目の人はもう全くもう関係なくなっちゃいますよと
ですから 彼女はあなた子供を産むことには全然協力するはずがないんだと
だからそれぐらいのことわからないんですかと
だから気をつけなさいと
ですから この気をつけなさいと言ったら
また妊娠するんですね
三回目に妊娠したら 言わない
隠しちゃったんです 妊娠したことは隠したって普通に生活する
隠すったっても まあそうずっと隠しておくわけにはいきませんだからね
お腹がどんどん大きくなるんだからね
お腹が大きくなってくる
お腹が大きくなってきたら
もうなんであんたのお腹が大きいでしょうかと 一番目の奥さんがね
と聞くと もう たら なんであなたに報告する必要あるんですかと
二回もあなたに言ったんですけど
子供は流産しちゃったんだと
ですから あんたに言わなかったんだよと
そこで一番目の女の人は
これで私も終わりますと
私の幸福も まあ大変なことになったということで
どうしようもないんですね
彼女は全くもうもうもう別に生活しているというか
もう一緒にご飯食べないと
それでも同じでいるんだからね
ちょっと隙間を見て 彼女にまた毒を飲ましちゃうんですね
毒を飲ましちゃったんだけど
もうお腹が大きいんですよ
ものすごく大きい だから子供がお腹の中でかなり大きくなっているんですね
それで子供はまあ一応毒ですからね
まあ死んじゃいますけど
でもあの死んだ子供はなかなかまあ外へ出てこないんですね
強引に薬ですから 子供が引っかかっちゃって
まあそれでその女の人死んでしまっちゃうんです
[背景のノイズ]そこでこの死にかけている女の人は
ものすごいもう嫌で もう怒りで狂ってるんですね
自分の子供を二人も殺した人だから
これは許すわけにはいきませんし
それ上もう3番目の子供を守る守ると頑張っていたのに
これ知らないうちにまた毒飲まされて飲まされちゃって
だから流産する時の毒だから
まあ普通はもう母親にはあまり影響はないんですけど
やっぱり子供が大きくなったところで
もう強烈なものを飲ませなくちゃいけないし
それでまあ子供もなかなか外へ出てこなかったし
それでまあ自分も死にかけちゃって
で まあ死ぬんです だからもうこの人が私の子供3人も殺して
最後に私まで殺してしまうんだと
ですから 私は生まれ変わって
すごいこの怒りで死んじゃいます
ったからね もうやりきれない気持ちで
自分ももう死にかけているし
死んでしまうし もう勝手にもう子供3人も私も殺しちゃったと
それで亡くなっちゃって
あるまあ夜叉の霊で心霊ですね
まあその悪霊ですね ある悪霊として生まれて生まれ変わるんですね
それで この霊にはこの彼女の子供をもう食べる能力があります
だから悪霊で もう霊になって生まれても
人間に誰にも邪魔できるわけじゃないんです
それもやっぱり業に誰をいじめるかということは決まってますからね
この女の霊がやっぱりこの相手の子供を食べるぐらいの能力は持っている
まあ彼女は死ぬ時はそういうふうに思って死にましたからね
一応 今度死んだら私はもう悪霊になってなってやるぞと
なってからその女の子供を全部食べるぞと
で 決めて死んじゃって
そういうふうに生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
でもいきなり悪霊になったわけじゃないんです
死んですぐこの どうなったんでしたっけ？マッジャーリですから
彼女はこの家でこの猫
猫として生まれ変わるんですね
メス猫で この死んだお母さんが
それであの まあ前の一番目のお母さんがこれ人殺したっていうことを知って
まあまあ旦那に殴られちゃって
で まあそれでまあ彼女も病気になって
まあ死んじゃいますね
死んでもその家にすごい執着があるんだから
まあ鶏として生まれるんです
そこで鶏っていうのは早く大きくなっちゃうし
まあ猫は先に生まれたしね
で この鶏が卵を産むまで待っていて
サッとこの猫が入ってそれ食べちゃうんです
狙っていくんです 卵産むまで待っていて
行って狙ってその卵を食べちゃう
また卵産むまで待っていて
また行ってそれ食べちゃうと
それで3回も卵を食べたんだと
卵を食べたらもうまた卵はないし
それで猫の狙いはこの鶏そのものを食べたくなっちゃうんですね
で 攻撃して まあやっぱり殺すんですよ
それでまた生まれ変わる2人も
そこで鶏が えーとっていうのは
まあ虎ではない 虎よりもうちょっと小さな Leopard
まあ豹みたい まあちょっと虎は虎ではないんですけど
評価この Leopard というね
もうちょっと虎より小さい
まあ虎系なんですけどね
そういう動物を通して生まれちゃうんですね
この鶏になった人が そこで猫になっていた女の人は
この鹿の口の中に生まれちゃうんですね
お腹の中に そこでその豹がやっぱり狙ってこの鹿の子供を食べちゃう
で もう回も子供を食べられちゃって
そこで その鹿も自分が死ぬ時は
また自分も攻撃されちゃうんですね
まあ自分も攻撃されちゃって
もう死にかけて 私の子供回も食べて
最後に私も殺して食べるんだと
このもう豹が ですから
これはなんとか仕返ししなくちゃいけないんだと
ですから 私もこの人の子供とこの人はとにかく食べてやるぞと
そこでもう最後に まあこの夜叉という悪霊の悪霊として生まれちゃうんですね
それで豹も亡くなって
普通の家で生まれるんです
人間として そこでこの悪霊が
まあまあ 何のことなくそちらに引っかかっ引かれちゃうんですね
惹かれて なんか随分このすごい親しい知ってる人の顔体を作って
そういう体になって家に行くんですね
家に行って 私のお友達はどこですか？と言ったら
まあ今家の中で子供を産んでいるんだと
ああ そうですか で 男ですか？女ですか？と聞いて
じゃあこれ見ないと じゃあ赤ちゃんを赤ん坊を見たいんだと
それで女の人がもう自分の友達やと言って赤ん坊を見たいと言ったんだから
まあまあ家に入れてあげるんですね
どうぞ入ってくださいと
それで家に入って赤ん坊を殺して帰っちゃうんです
まあ食べると書いてますけどね
まあそれは分かりませんですけどね
赤ん坊を食べて帰っちゃうんです
それでまた回目 また回も子供を食べられて
回目もまた子供も そこでお母さん回も妊娠したら
お母さんがやっぱりこの家に来て
回も回も子供を食べられた
亡くなったんだ これはもう悪霊ですよと
だからこの家に来るんだから
私は別なところで子供を産みますよと言って
自分の家に行くんです
そこで 悪霊たちにも悪霊の世界でいろいろ決まりがあります
[背景音楽]どんな人の家にも入ることもできないし
誰に迷惑をかけるかっていうことは
やっぱりこれは割り当てがあるんです
霊の世界で そこで彼女にはこの悪霊の王様がいるんですよ
その王様っていうのは
この帝釈天の毘沙門天なんですよ
で 毘沙門天の家来なんです
それでこの毘沙門天に
神様に 王様に お仕えをしなくちゃいけない当番があるんです
みんなやらなくちゃいけない
それで自分の当番が回ってきて
で それは断れない 税金払ってるような感じですけどね
それで行って この毘沙門天のところに行って
その仕事をする 仕事をして
仕事終わったら だいたいその毘沙門天は何か希望
何か聞いてしてあげるんですね
だからいろんな神話の中で
いろんな悪霊たちでも
誰かに何か迷惑をかけたいと思ってもできないんだと
そうすると 思い存分自分の上の王様に一生懸命お仕えしてしてして
何か私にもちょっとした
この何て言いますか この頼み事があるんだよと
ですから 頼み事を聞いて
頼み事なりに仕事量が減る
増えるんですよ それで仕事をちゃんとこなしたら
では頼み事は条件付きで認められたりする場合もあります
例えば誰が殺したいんだったら
ではあなたには一年以内
で認めてあげるというと
この一年以内にその人を殺さないとあかんですよ
一年経っちゃうともうできません
力がないんです そんな感じで
だからそれは霊の話で
彼女はこの まあこちらでは水汲みに行くんだという話でね
まあそれはどういうことかわかりませんですけど
このかなり大変な重労働みたいですね
この王様の仕事に行ったら
時々五か六か月間 五か月間とか
まあずっと続けて仕事をしなくちゃいかないんだそうです
その途中でこのもう死ぬ人々も霊もいるんだよと
なんか奴隷みたいな感じなんですね
どうせ天国 天界ではないんだからね
ですから 仕事をさせるはさせるは
途中で死んでしまっちゃう場合もあるんだと
彼女はまあ精勤深いんだから
とにかくこの 頑張ってこの仕事当番終わるんですね
仕事当番終わったらもう自由になるんです
なったら あの私の友達はどこですかと
で まあ調べるんですよ
そこで家に行って この私の友達はどこですか？って言ったら
今はこちらにいませんと
なんでしょうかという
こちらには悪霊が来て
子供はもう二回も殺されちゃったんだからね
彼女は自分の家に行ったんだと
と言って悪霊に言うんですよ
そこでこの その悪霊にとっては
その家で生まれたならば食べられる
殺すことはできます 他のところで生まれたならば
どうすることもできない
えーと そこで彼女がそう簡単に私から逃げ
逃げてたまるかと言って
すぐもうさっさとその女を追っているところに行く
女の人は子供を産んで何日も経って
もう名前もつけて もう大丈夫やというところで
初めて子供は週間ぐらいでも大きくなりましたからね
で 自分の家のね 親に では私はもう子供はもうこれで安心やと思いますよと
ということで帰るんです
で 帰る途中で こちらは向こう
こちらはこの女の人会いに
まあ悪霊が行くんですよ
向こうはもう子供が産んで大きくなって
もう帰ってくる それで帰る途中で
このジェートーナラームですよ
お釈迦様が住んでいる
お寺のそこらすごい大きい巨大な公園でしたからね
そちらはみんな一般の人々も出入りしたり
まあもう 森もありましたし
いろいろ使っているんですね
お寺といって別に閉めてドアをかけてあるわけじゃないんです
すごい大きな公園でしょうし
で 彼女がもう帰っている途中で
旦那さんと一緒にまあ沐浴したくなるんですね
で 沐浴して 旦那さんがまたあの
まあお寺の井戸なんで
井戸で言ったって みんな入って沐浴するんだから
大きくできたものやと思いますけど
たくさん人々入るものだからね
お寺の井戸で沐浴して
自分が子供におっぱいをあげている
その間旦那さんが沐浴している
それでこの悪霊の女の人ももうさっさと見つけて
そちらへんに飛んでくるんですね
飛んでくると このお母さんがすぐもう分かったんですね
前も回も来たのはこの人やと
わかって旦那にもうものすごく叫ぶんですよ
大変だ 早く上がってこい
上がってこいと あの女は女ではなくて
あの女がこの悪霊ですよと
この女にこの子供殺されるんだよと
言っても もう沐浴している旦那がすぐ上がってきて
もう女の人を追っ払うことというのはできないし
お母さんだからもう待っていられないし
そのまま子供を抱っこして逃げちゃう
逃げたっても逃げる所もないし
まあ公園で森でしょうし
とにかくお坊さんたちやらお釈迦様たち
そこら辺には建物あるんだから
そこら辺に逃げてしまったんです
そこでお寺の領域ありますね
一応 建物とか作って お坊さんたちやらお釈迦様やら住んでいるところ
その中に入ってしまったんです
入ってしまったら お釈迦様のところでお坊さんたちがみんな集めて説法を聞いている
彼女は誰か人間がいるところにいないと不安だからね
人間の真ん中では何もできませんからね
もう誰にでも だからお坊さんがいるところに走ってきたら
もう真ん中にお釈迦様いるし
みんな周りお釈迦様を囲まって座っているし
子供を持っていてお釈迦様の前に置いといて
なんとかその子供を守ってくださいと
お釈迦様の足元にそのまま置いておいたんです
それで彼女はトゥンマカンマヤエーサディンノ
この子供 子供をあなたにあげますよと
お釈迦様にあげるんです
あなたにあげますから
その子 でも私の息子の命だけ守ってくださいと
あなたにあげますからと
お釈迦様にあげちゃう
お釈迦様は命を守ってくれと
とにかく母親だから 子供だけ
命だけ守ってくれればいいということで
この悪霊がもう追ってきたんだけど
寺は神々に守られている
寺のところは ですから
すごい格が違う 神と悪霊の場合
役者と平和っていうのはかなり格が違うんです
で もう入らないんです
まあ断るんで入るなよと
で 入らないで待っている
そこでお釈迦様が自分の足元に赤ちゃん赤ん坊がいるわ
で お釈迦様はなんのことなくアーナンダ尊者に呼んで
玄関のところに雑霊がいるんですけど
呼びなさいと こちらに
行ったら まあアーナンダ尊者はもう何のことなく玄関に行ったら
女の人が悪霊ですけど
人間の形をとって待っているし
行ったらお釈迦様はまた呼びます
呼んでおりますよと言ったら入るんですね
お釈迦さんに呼ばれたんだから
入るとまたあの女の人がすごく怯えて
お母さんがまた泣き叫ぶ
ものすごく叫ぶんですね
この女の人に殺されるんだ
殺されるんだと お釈迦様はね
まあまあ落ち着きなさいよと
私の前でそんなことできるわけないんだと
お前ももうちょっと落ち着いたらどうですかと
黙っていなさいとお母さんに黙せちゃうんですね
私の前では虫一匹にも何の恐怖感も生まれませんと
ですから あなたみたいな人間はなんで怯えるんですかと
落ち着いて心配しないで座りなさいって言ったら
彼女はお釈迦様の言葉だから黙って座る
その悪霊も来る そちらに
えーと そこでお釈迦様はその二人に
今前に言ったナヒヴェーレナヴェーラニという言葉中心にして説法するんですね
二人にも だから説法したら
やっぱり悪いのは誰かというと
どちらもどちらでしょうに
だから普通だったらもう人を殺したんだから
もう殺したあなたが悪いと一方的に言いますけど
仏教から見れば まあ殺す側も原因があって殺すんであって
殺される側も原因があって殺されるんであって
で 今世でそれはわからないんだからといって
まあそれでは問題は済みませんと
例えばこのまあ何年か前に世田谷の方で家族みんな殺しちゃったでしょ
誰に殺されたか なんで殺されたかと
さっぱりもわからない
いまだに何の情報もない
なんか靴一つの跡があるんだよとかね
何かジャンパーはこのジャンパーだよというだけで
もう人は確定することは全くできない
だから 何も罪のない 何も悪いことをしていない人がなんで殺されるんでしょうかと
我々はいろいろ悩んだりしたっても
やっぱりそうやって突然誰かに来て
家みんないっぺんに殺される場合は
やっぱりそれなりの不幸に出会う業を持ってるんですよ
今世では何も悪いことしてないのは誰でも知ってますけど
ごく普通に豊かで穏やかに生活しているのは
これは誰でも知ってるんですけど
しかし なんで突然殺された
殺されたかというと やっぱり殺す側もそれなりにこいつを狙うぞということになっちゃうし
例えば大阪で小学生の小学校の子供たち人ぐらい殺されちゃったでしょうね
宅間というね なんとか精神的な異常者がね
だからこのまあなんか裁判で言ったというニュースで聞いたんですけどね
やっぱりもう誰がこれなんでしょう
あの小学校 やっぱり豊かな裕福な家庭の子供たちを選んだ方がいいと思ったんだよと
やっぱり本人がその学校を
その子供たちっていうものを狙っちゃうんですよ
だから ここら辺 どこら辺
他のどんな小学校選んだっていいでしょうに
人を殺すに しかし 自分の憎しみに
自分の悩みに なんで子供を殺さなくちゃいけないかと
他の人を殺しちゃえばいいでしょうし
やっぱりそのその人に
そういうふうに頭がおかしくなって
そういう選択をしてしまっちゃうんですね
だからやっぱり仏教から言えば
それは原因わからないものやというふうに仏教は言いたくはないんですよ
ある日 突然人が精神的に異常になって
誰かを殺しちゃったんだと
ですから それは突然な出来事やということは仏教は言わないんですね
物事っていうのは突然は起こらないっていうのは因果法則の立場なんですね
突然何か起こるっていうことはありえないんですね
突然だったら このマイクロフォンは突然花になったとかね
突然ネズミになったとかね
言うならば突然というのを成り立つんですよ
やっぱりこれは決して花にはならないし
ネズミにもなりませんね
だから起こる出来事にはちゃんと原因はあるんですよ
これに突然になろうと思っちゃうと
誰かが走ってきて 歩いていて
何かもう壊しちゃうとかね
まあそれぐらいのものはあり得るんですけどね
マイクロフォンはもう踏まれて踏んでしまって壊れたんだと
それ以外のことはっていうのはあり得るんでしょうかと
だからそれも突然というわけでもないんですよ
まあ例えばこれ買った人が
まあなんかどこかでもう一度お金を払わなくちゃいけない羽目になってるならばね
過去の業で もう誰かが随分丁寧にこちら気を付けて歩いたとしても
その人の足がこけちゃって
やっぱり踏んでしまう可能性はありますね
その時も誰かに踏まれたわけでもなくて
やっぱりその人に踏まれるはずなんですよ
そうすると この損した人も
この人はもういい加減で不注意でというふうに
その人に対して恨みや憎しみを持っていることになっちゃうんですね
ですから 突然な突然物事は起こらないというのは
まあ一応仏教の立場なんですね
世の中では突然アクシデントという原因は使うんです
アクシデントということは原因はないんだよと
でも この宇宙で この生命の中で
何一つも突然起きたっていうことはありえないんです
ちゃんと原因が揃ったところで結果が出る
あれは我々は種を植えたら突然花が咲くことは全然ないんです
芽が出て 葉っぱが出て
成長して花が咲くというふうな順番で
ちゃんと原因が揃ったら起こるもんなんですね
だから一切の物事は 一切の出来事は
ちゃんと原因があって生まれるんだよというのが仏教の立場
それで人間たちは自分で原因がわからない時は
これは突然やと これは神様が決めたんだと平気で言うんで
あれはもういい加減な言い方なんですね
科学者も平気で言うんですね
それは神様の仕事だから我々わかりませんよと
科学者にとっても まあここまでわかったんだけど
これ先はわからないんだと
そういうふうに言うべきところはね
今の研究能力ではもうそれ以上は知ることはできません
言っておけばいいのに
平気で神様 神様と言うんですね
ですから それはね 私たちは原因知らないんだからといって
何かいい加減なことを言ってはいけません
人が生まれた時からもうすごい病弱でと生まれるかもしれません
それはなんで神様が私の子は病弱にしたんでしょうかとかね
誰も病弱にしたわけじゃないんですけど
それなりの原因があってそうなっているんであって
ですから原因がわかるとまあ落ち着くんですよ
ですから 妄想で強引に落ち着くんじゃなくて
ちゃんと原因を知って落ち着いた方がいいのです
しかし 問題は 私たち人間には何だかんだも原因が見つかることはできないのです
なんであの人は背が伸びないんですか？なんでこの人は背が余計に伸びるんですか？なんであの人はすごい元気でいるんですか？なんでこの人は病弱ですかとかね
そんなのを人間に知るということはほとんど不可能でしょうし
不可能だったら知りませんというところで止まった方がいいのに
誰かの霊能者やら神に成り上がっている誰かから何か聞いて
ああ なるほど そういうことですかとすごい納得するんですね
何も証拠も何もないものをしゃべるんだからね
で あの それで全ては知ることは不可能ですし
そんな能力は人間にはないんです
人間に知ることができるのはほんのちょっとのことなんです
世界の中では 人間には完全には自分のことだったら知り得るんだから
自分のことを研究しなさいと仏教は言っているんです
自分の心を研究すると
自分の心の回転見えてくるし
そうするとなんで自分が不幸ですか？なんで自分に友達がないんですか？とかね
自分でわかるんですよ
自分がそういうふうに考えているんだからそうなっているんだと
では違う方向で考えると
どうもそれ無理やと 例えばいつでも人は軽視する
人をバカにしちゃうと軽視しちゃうと全然友達が出てこないんですね
それを教えてあげたって
それは悪いとは知ってはいるんですけど
すぐ喋るともう何か相手を貶してるんですね
それでちゃんと自分の心を研究してみると
なるほど 自分がこういうパターンで生きてきたんだから
ずっと不幸な人生になってしまったと
では 自分の思考パターン変えられますかないかと頑張ってみればいいということで
だから自分の心知っておけば
それで十分です 人のものまで知ろうとするんじゃなくて
宇宙のことまでも知ろうとするんじゃなくて
そんなのは自分にとっては全然関係も何もないものなんですね
だから地球がいつ現れたっても
これはどうでもいいことで
恐竜はなんで亡くなったんでしょうか？と知ったとしても
知らなくたっても どうでもいいことで
一番必要なのは自分を知ることなんですね
なんで自分が怠け者ですかとかね
なんで自分の頭が悪いんですかとかね
それで自分を知っておくと
問題は一応解決するんです
それでみんな期待するのは
自分のことを全くも知ろうとしないで
人のことをなんとかしてくれませんかと
私にも頼まれる時もあります
姑さんがすごい厳しくて
もうわがままで ものすごい性格が悪いんだと
だからどうすればよろしいかと
それは姑さんのことをどうすることもできんでしょうに
そういう環境 自分との関係だから言っているのは
姑さんと自分との関係でしょうに
だからそれは自分の心の働きによって成り立つものであって
だから人のことではなくて
自分の心は心を研究するしか解決方法はないんです
だから姑さんが悪いんだから姑さんが殴るんですかね
私が行って 全然知らない人に説教するんですかね
そんなのはありえないでしょ
成り立たないでしょうに
ですから 相手に当たるということは全くもやってはいけないこと
でも世の中でよくよくやるんですよ
世の中であるのは自分は正しい
間違っているのは相手だと
宗教も同じなんです キリスト教にしたっても
イスラム教にしたっても
自分が正しい 間違っているのはあなた方だよと
あんた方は神を信仰していないんだと
だから死んだっても地獄に落ちるんだよと
あんた方のせいで悪魔が一生懸命頑張ってるんだよと
ということで相手を殺しに行くんですね
どんな問題にしたっても
国際国の問題にしたっても
私たちのせいではありませんと
隣の国が悪いんだと 言って戦争しなくちゃいけないんだと
そういう風にいつでも相手に相手のせいにする
やっぱり問題っていうのは
誰かのせいにしちゃうと解決しません
それですごく不幸な結果しか出てこない
そういうことだから このストーリーでもやっぱり言いたがっているのは
お釈迦様のところにある女の人が子供を抱っこして来たんだと
他の女の人はその子供を殺そうとしているんだと
それだけ見たら その殺してる女が完璧に頭がおかしくて悪いんですよ
例えばある女の人の子供が関係ない他の女の人が殺そうとしていると
これが明らかにとんでもないことでしょうね
でも そういう不自然なことっていうのは起こりませんというのを我々言ってる立場なんですね
それが不自然でしょう
例えば 電車に乗って 誰か子供を抱っこして電車に乗っていると
隣にどこか他のところに座っている人が突然来て
あの子供の首をひねって殺してしまうというのはね
そういう面ではすごく不自然でしょうし
それでみんな精神的な異常者や何とか何とか言ってごまかしはするんですけど
そういう不自然なものっていうのは起こりません
世の中何一つも すべてのものにはちゃんとした原因はあります
原因通りに自然法則によって物事は起きるんです
だから電気流しちゃうと
この冷房から冷風が出してくれる
電気でやってるんだからといって
冷房からじゃあ光も出してもらおうと
照明も踏ん張っても これは照明は出してくれないんですよ
せっかくたくさんの蛍光灯あるんだから
蛍光灯から空気も冷たくしてもらいましょうと思ったって
それは無理でしょうに
だから自然の流れで蛍光灯だったら電気流れると光を出してくれる
冷房だったら電気流してくれると冷たい風を出してくれるとか
当たり前のことなんで
だから当たり前のことしか起こりません
それを言いたがっている男なんですね
それにはもう何回も過去世まで飛ばさないと
この法則がなかなかわかってくれない
ですから このストーリーで見ると
最初に一番目の奥さんが家の奥さんで
家の主人で財産を管理している
本人から見てもやっぱり子供がないとこっていうのはちょっとまずいんですね
女の立場から見れば 子供が産めないということはすごく大変な精神的な問題なんですね
それからインド社会では
子供は産めない女っていうのは
ものすごい不幸な人間だと
社会からも不幸人物扱いするんですよ
あまり信頼はされません
お母さんたちだったらいつでも信頼される
子供が産んだことがあるんだったら
もういくら年取っても
歳になっても もう歳になっても
まあ随分信頼される そういう社会的な状況もあります
今もないわけじゃないんですよ
子供は産んでない 女の人っていうのは
ちょっとみんなほんのちょっと注意するんですよ
注意しましょうと どこかでちょっとおかしいところあるんだよと
すぐ見えるのは この女性にあるべき優しさが消えちゃうんですよ
すごい残酷的になっちゃう
年取ればきつくなるんですよ
社会性がどんどんできなくなっちゃうんですね
みんなと仲良くワイワイとね
生活することはできなくなっちゃう
だからそれは女性にとってはすごく必要なことなんですね
いつでもグループを組んで
噂話やら世間ブダ話ばっかりしながら
それでも落ち着いて生活するんだからね
これができなくなるとなかなか大変ですよ
それはそう置いといて
とにかくまあ 彼女の立場から見れば
自分がこの遠い昔のね
社会で 自分には子供が産めないと
不幸な女やと言われるし
それで本人がやっぱり
じゃあまあ二人で子供を作ればどうでしょうかと考えた可能性もあるし
自分も何とか参加しよう
でもやっぱり自然的にやっぱり嫉妬はまた出てくる
いくらなんでも子供っていうのは産んだ母親のところに行っちゃうし
私には立場がなくなっちゃうんだよ
ですから まあやっぱりその自分の心にある嫉妬やら
自分の立場やら 財産に対する執着やらね
そういうものから悪いことをするように
なってしまうんですね
それでなんでその子供を殺したかというと
やっぱりその子供が産んだら自分の幸福がなくなるんですよ
ですから 番目の奥さんの子供は殺すんですよ
隣の家の子供を殺しちゃっても
自分には何の意味もないんですよ
だから その最初に子供を殺した時でも
隣の家の子供を殺そうとは全然思わない
自分でも子供が欲しい
だから子供に対してはもう大変親切やと思いますよ
親切なんですけど やっぱりこの人が子供を産んじゃうと困ると
ということになるんですね
ですから 番目の奥さんの子供を狙っちゃうんですね
それで妊娠する子供たちも
もう生まれることもできなくて流産しちゃうでしょうに
やっぱりそれはそちらの業で
この世の光を見る運命はない
生まれる前も死んでしまうちゃうということになるんです
成長する業があって生まれるんだったら
とにかくなんとか生まれますよ
そういうことで やっぱりどちらでもどっちもどっちということなんですね
とにかく仏教は他人に文句言うということはやめてほしいんですね
どちらでもどちらですよと
だから自分だけ悪いということでもないし
相手だけ悪いということでもないんです
冷静に世の中で生きてみなさいと
私は何にも悪いことをしていないのに
なんでこういう風になるんでしょうかという風に文句言う必要はないんだと
どこかでそれなりの五分五分の
条件というのは揃っているんだよと
で 彼女に この鬼に またお母さんにお釈迦様が二人にも違ってね
あなた方二人ともまあどちらでもどちらですよと
で 説法したところで その問題は解決します
とにかくこの 鬼だからね
相手の女の人は  お釈迦様
過去生をまあ ずっと言うんですよ
あなた方 互いに殺し合いやってね
ずっと続けてくるんだよと
こんなことでどこまでやるんですかと
今あなたが殺して 次はもうあなたの子供を殺される
次はまたあなたのあなたが殺しに行くと
終わりがないんだよと
いい加減に仲直りしなさいと
その説法を聞いて この鬼がやっぱり悟るんです
鬼が心はきれいになったなとお釈迦様がわかって
それでやっと問題は解決しましたと
第1番目に悟ったら もう殺生はしません
戒律はちゃんと守る そこまでは守ることはない
それでもお母さん 人間のお母さんにとってはすごい心配でしょうしね
それでお釈迦様がこのお母さんにその赤ちゃんをね
この人にあげなさいと
抱っこさせなさいと 言ったらまた怯えるんですね
もうもう二人も殺されちゃったんだから
それで自分であげなさいと言っちゃうと
もうこれはできるわけじゃないし
怯えちゃうんですね それでも心配するなよと
ちゃんとあげなさいと言ったら
もうどうしようもないし
お釈迦様には断ることは人間にも誰にもできません
ですから 震えながら鬼の女に子供をあげるんですよ
あげたらその人は子供を抱っこして
もうすごく可愛がって
可愛い可愛いとかなんとか言ったりしてね
可愛がってあげて そこでやっぱり子供も可愛がるものだというふうに感情が生まれたでしょうしね
で またお母さんにまたはい
どうぞ あなたの子供 ちゃんと元気で育ってくださいと
この殺しにかけた殺しに来た鬼の女が帰してあげるんですね
それで二人が随分それっきりで
問題は終わり 仲直りと
とにかくこの鬼の女が赤ちゃんを抱っこして
ちゅうをして可愛がってあげて
お母さんにまた帰してあげて
自分が泣き出したんですよ
で 泣くとこの鬼にお釈迦様はなんであんた泣くんですか？と聞いたら
私は鬼で もうなんとか何とか苦労して生きてきたんだと
それでも鬼になってから一度もお腹いっぱい食べたこともないんだと
それからもうもう第1番目に悟り
夜かに悟ってみるでしょうし
だから悪いことは決してしてはいけない
鬼っていうのはいろいろ悪いことをして
自分栄養をとってるんですね
だから これから私はどうすればいいかと
今まで鬼としてあらゆる人に迷惑をかけて
人からお供えものを奪ったりして
生活をしていたんですけど
これからはそれはできない
人を脅してまあお供えものをもらうこともできない
まあこれから私はもうまあ飢え死になるってことなんですね
泣いちゃうんですよ 泣いちゃうと
お釈迦様はもうもうあんた心配するなよと言って
まああのお母さんにね
お前はね この鬼をね まあまあ人間の形はこれから消えますからね
この鬼を自分の家に呼びなさいよと
だから霊っていうのは
この人間のところで許可あったら住めるんですよ
ですから お前 あなたはこの鬼をね
自分の家に連れて行って住む
住むようにしてくださいと
もともともその鬼にはその家に入る権利というか能力はあったんですね
もともと でも子供殺しに行くんですからね
だから他の人の家には行けない
入れません 王様から許可ないと
それはなかなか得られない
ですから あなたは家に連れて行ってくださいと
家に連れて行って 毎日ちゃんとご飯やらいろいろお供えものをしてあげてくださいと
人間がいろんなそうやってお供えやらいろんなことをすると
それでその霊の世界で何か立場があって生きているみたいんですね
で 彼女は家に連れて行って
家の梁の上に一応それなりに何か作って
あんたこちらに住みなさいと
入れてはおいたんですけど
家でこの昔は籾をね あれで臼で米にしなくちゃいけないんだからね
それかなりうるさいんですよ
振動するんですね それでこの鬼にはもうもう朝から昼も時間ない
いつでも籾をもう打ってるんだからね
この音はすごく振動して
もう生きていられないんだと
だから私に他の場所を欲しいやと言われたら
また家の中で他のところ
じゃあこちらどうでしょうかと
やっぱりこちらもダメですよと
と では家の外はどうですかと言っちゃうと
家の外は牛やら犬やら行ったり来たり行ったり
もうやっぱりもういられないんだと
で あっちこっちこの鬼を連れて行って
いろんなところに住んでもらいますけど
あまりこの場所が良くないんですね
子供たちが遊んでいる場合
これはもう無理だとかね
あっちもちょっと無理
無理よとかね 言って 結局村の中にはもう場所がなくて
それで村の領域がないところに人がそんなに出入りしないところに行って
こちらで何かあんたに作ってあげますよということで
お堂みたいなものを作ってあげて
こちらはどうですか？こちらは楽でよろしいと
そこで彼女が彼女に毎日お供え物を持っていくんだからね
このお母さんが で 彼女もこの女の人にだけ言うんですよ
他の人とはコンタクト取れないしね
他の人は見えませんし
で 雨が降る時期になってくると
もうちゃんとこの時期になってくると雨が降ります
降りますよと この時期はずっと全然雨が降らない乾季ですよとかね
そうやって必要なデータを与える
それに合わせて その家の農作物作るなり作らないことにも雨が降らなかったらね
田んぼはできませんし
それだったら他の野菜作ればいいしね
それなりに生活して 村人はみんなものすごく豊かになりましたと
[背景の音楽]それで村人はみんなあの損はすることなく
例えば田んぼを作ったんだけど
洪水で流しちゃうと流せて流してしまっちゃうと何もないでしょうに
だから今年は洪水だよと言ったら
まあもう知ってますから
どこどこまで洪水になるんでしょうか
そうすると村人はみんなまあ今年はこういうふうなことをしましょうと
それに合わせて生活する
今年は乾季だと言ったら
では我々はこういうことをしましょうと
そういうふうに人間もみんなこの豊かになってしまったと
そこで村人もお供えすることに
やっぱりこの鬼のおかげでこんなに豊かになっているんだから
あなただけを供養して困る必要ないんだと言って
村人やらみんなもうずっととにかく神社というかね
そういうふうな感じになってしまったんだと
そこであの鬼も今までお腹いっぱい食べたことはなかったんですけど
今はもう町から町からね
もう人々が大勢集めてきて
そちらにお供え物を持ってきて
いろいろお願い事を願を立てたり
いろんなことをしてるんだから
かなり向こうも商売繁盛ですね
鬼もまあ随分贅沢に生きることはできたと
ということで これ名前はカーリという鬼なんですね
で カーリ女神というインドの伝統的なこの悪霊というか
女神で女の幽霊 悪霊ですね
で この信仰はあったんです
昔から昔 この女の鬼を信仰
鬼ではない女の神ですね
女の神を信仰するカーリというのは未だにいるんです
カーリ女神で インド今もすごい恐ろしい神なんですよ
子供の首を切って 手でこうやって持ってて
口にも赤ん坊も横にしてくわえていて
もうもう口からものすごくこのもう血が出ていて
というすごい恐ろしい形で作るんです
インドに行ったらカーリの神社っていうのはあります
いまだにその神社に人々が行って生贄するんです
あの だいたい鶏か山羊です
で 殺してお供えする インドでそういう伝統が今も続けている
だいたいこの呪う時は
その神社には必ず行くんですね
人を呪う時は しかし インドではこのカーリ神っていうのは
このそれほど恐ろしい神というよりも
すごい守ってくれる神としても思っているんですね
それでカーリ神の乗り物は虎なんです
だからこのヒョウでもないんですけど
ですから インドで行けば
インドのトラックやら
こうやってこの長距離運転する人
仕事の人 人々の車には必ずしも虎の置物が一つあるんです
車に描いてあるか 前にあるか
中にあるか 何か置物か何かあるんです
この虎あるっていうことは
カーリ神を守ってくださいということなんです
で それはヒンドゥー教の思考で
このストーリーでこのカーリ神に対する信仰っていうのはなかなか消えませんだから
この神を一応仏教徒にしてしまえばいいんじゃないかと
ということで仏教徒にしているんですね
仏教徒にして 殺生は断る
ですから 呪いの神ではなくて
人殺しの神ではなくて
人々を守る恵み女神にしちゃうんですね
仏教はわざわざと だから
この神の物語 この夜叉の鬼の物語をきれいに変えて
まあ悪いことをしないように
動物でも殺さないように
呪いの神ではなくて 恵みを与えてくれる神ではないかと
だから人を呪うためにいろいろなことをするなよというね
まあそういう話ではないかなと思います
で 日本では 日本でも信仰しています
その神は 何でしたっけ？日本では鬼子母神というね
子供を守る神として日本でも信仰しています
でもテーラワーダ世界ではこのストーリーはちゃんと知ってますけど
信仰していないんです
仏教の神々の話はさんさん出てくるんだけど
なんか不思議に信仰はしないんですね
私もみんなこの伝統的ないろんな信仰あるんだからね
自分たちが仏教だったら
仏教仏典に出てくる神々ぐらい信仰したっていいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
やらないんですね 例えばお釈迦様のいつでも仲のいい家来みたいな感じで
いろいろお世話する神として帝釈天が出てくる
で なんかすごい面白いシーンが
時々帝釈天がお釈迦様に会いたいんだけど
なかなか久しぶりだから叱られると怯えて
お釈迦さんに何か言われちゃうと
これはもうどうかなとか
ちょっと会わないという時もありますね
それで自分の他の家来の神を頼んでね
君がちょっとお釈迦様に行ってみたらどうですかとかね
私も来ているんだよとかね
まあそれぐらいちょっとした可愛らしい性格なんですよ
それでまあもう帝釈天のこの側近の神がいて
お釈迦様に会って話をして
実は私は一人で来たんじゃないんだよと
私の主人も帝釈天も来ていますよと言ったら
じゃああの人を呼びなさいよと
お釈迦様は一言言うんですね
言うと帝釈天にOKだよ
出ますよと言ったら 何のことなくこそこそとお釈迦様のところに来る
来て お釈迦様とお話を
お釈迦様わかるんです
この人ちょっと遠慮していたんだと
その時は叱ったりもしないで
何か教えてあげたりもするし
それでお釈迦様一回ものすごく病気になって倒れたんですね
病気になって倒れたんですけど
お釈迦様はもう誰にも来るなよとみんな追い出しちゃったんです
一人でいたいんだと でもお釈迦様一人でものすごく病気になって倒れてということはもう大変でしょうし
それで人間はもう近くお釈迦様に断られた
もう入れないんだから
それで帝釈天がこれ大変だと思って
自分がこの病気治るまでお釈迦様のお世話したんです
全部お世話もして で それでこの天国から降りてきて
その時でも君はもう神々も他のサーリプッタたちね
あなたはね 人間の体ってあなた方にとってはものすごい臭いでしょうにと
もう体が震えるほど臭いんだそうです
人間が 神々にとっては
それなのにまた病気でお釈迦様の面倒よく見たもんだなと
どうやって我慢したんですか？と
で 帝釈天何言うんですかとお釈迦様のことっていうのは
私にとってはもう天国にある花の香りよりも香りですよと
お釈迦様の便所掃除とか全部やってあげたみたい
で それはもう花の香りよりも香りですよと
お釈迦様は私にそれ許してあげたことほどありがたいことはないんだと
それぐらい仏教徒は随分お釈迦様と仲がいいんですけど
それだったら仏教徒も帝釈天にと
まあもう仲良くした方がいいんですけど
なんか分からないんだけど
あんまりもう気にしないんですね
無視されてるんです 良くないなと思いますけど
四天王も同じでね かなりお釈迦様との仲がいいんですけど
大乗仏教では四天王の仏像じゃなくて神の像を作ったりはしていますけどね
真言密教とかはね それだけのことで
テーラワーダの世界ではないね
わからない ヒンドゥー教が嫌だからね
そこら辺でもうその嫌みがずっと続けているかと
どう見ても元をたどってみればヒンドゥー教の神々だからね
だからもうもう嫌やと
ふうな思っている可能性もあるし
で ヒンドゥー教の神を礼するんだったら
ヒンドゥー教の神としてはっきりと区別して
宗教の何と言いますか
コミュニケーションとして仲良くしましょうと
みんなでどんな信仰があっても
ということで このアイデンティティを壊さなかったという可能性もあります
ですから ヒンドゥーの神々には一応ちょっとした場所を作ってあげるんですよ
正真正銘のヒンドゥーの神なんですけど
その時はちゃんとアイデンティティは壊してない
これはヒンドゥー教の神々ですよということで
まあなんかわからないんですけど
まあそこまで深くは人間というのは考えませんから
ですからまあ一応 学問的に分析してみると
まあなかなか大変なところにはなりますね
おそらくヒンドゥー教はちゃんとした生きてる宗教だから
仏教よりは力強いし 大きいし
だから堂々と仏教の神々にしてしまって
使うと もう一緒に合体になっちゃうと困るんですね
ヒンドゥー教はすごい手強いし
もうタコみたいに何でも吸収するというかね
ですからこのこのヒンドゥー教の直属にはすごい仏教徒は気を付ける
この吸血鬼というかね
他の宗教はすぐ吸収するんですね
で それを壊してしまっちゃうんです
自分たちの教えなこと何もないんですね
ヒンドゥー教の教えはなんですか？じゃないんだから
むちゃくちゃたくさんいろんなものある
猿の形の人を見て 裸で修行する人を見て
贅沢真っ最中の人を見て
もう動物殺したりしたりするところもあって
もうまるっきり動物殺すところがもうもう厳密に菜食主義やってる人を見て
もうもう断食する人を見て
どちらかとハッキリしないんですよ
だから神々もものすごいたくさんなるし
まあそれで吸収しやすいんですね
ヒンドゥー教っていうのは多宗教
だからもうこいつらに吸収されて殺されたらたまるかっていうことで
すごい自分 仏教というアイデンティティをものすごく別にしてる可能性もあります
それだったら それでもお互いに共存しなくちゃいけないんだから
では あなた方の神々にもちゃんと礼をしましょうということで
そういうふうな態度をとっている可能性もあります
カーリ女神はそんな 鬼子母神の話はそういう話なんですね
一般的にはこの生贄とかなんとかするんじゃなくて
ただご飯やらね おかゆとかね
そんなものあげなさいよと
どうしても神々に霊に幽霊にお供えしたければ
誰にも迷惑 かけないで
自分食べるご飯とかね
そんなものでやりなさいと言ってるとこなんです
それで偈に入ります ナヒヴェーレーナヴェーラーニサッマンティーダクダーチャナン
アヴェーレーナチャサッマンティーエーサダンマサナンタノ
ナヒヴェーレーナヴェーラーニサッマンティーダクダーチャナン
アヴェーレーナチャサッマンティーエーサダンモサナンタノ
ヴェーレーナヴェーラーニ
ヴェーレーナっていうのは怒りですね
恨みですね 恨みは恨みでは消えませんと
サッマンティーダっていうのは消えていくこと
この世の中でイダっていうのはこの世の中でサッマンティっていうのは消えていく
穏やかになるという 怒りは怒りでは穏やかになって消えていくことはないと
ナヒっていうのは決してありませんと
クダーチャナンっていうのはまた決してって意味なんですね
だから決してということは回使っているんです
ナッとのところでヒという言葉とクダーチャナンというのは
クダーチャナンというのはどんな日でもどんな時代でもありえないという時間的な言葉なんですね
いつの時代でも どんな時でも
恨みは恨みでは消えませんよと
アヴェーレーナチャサッマンティ
恨みないことで 怒らないことで
いわゆる慈しみですね
慈しみで恨みは憎しみは消えていくんだよと
エーサダンモ これは真理だよと
サナンタノ 永遠の真理だよと
普遍的な真理だよと だから意味は複雑ではありません
でも この態度っていうのは
当たり前やと思うんだけど
当たり前じゃないんだよ
これは仏教でしか言ってない態度なんです
正当な怒りがありますよというのは普通なんですよ
恨むなかれと言っているキリスト教でも
イエス様の宗教にしたっても
結局正当な怒りは認めるんですね
だから神を信じない人の罪は滅びませんだからね
だからそこら辺はイエス様でも何か一言葉言っておけばよかったのに
自分の教え崩れちゃいますわ
その場合はね やっぱりまあほっぺた殴ったら右のほっぺたも向きなさいとは言ってますよ
で それはもう逆襲するなよって意味なんですけど
でもそんなに完璧な言葉じゃないんですよ
もう悟ってない普通の人々だから
やっぱりいくらかはやっぱり人は憎しみよりは許してあげた方がいいんじゃないかなというぐらいの知恵はあるんですね
しかし 知り尽くしたわけじゃないんです
この法則を だから殴ってくる人にほっぺた
じゃあこちら殴ってくださいと言うだけで何もわからないでしょうね
回殴られるだけで終わっちゃいますけどね
回殴られるだけじゃなくて
それでもその人の怒りが消えるかどうかまだわからないでしょうに
ではなんでほっぺたか殴ったらあんた逃げなさいよと言わないんですかね
逃げちゃったら一回だけで終わりますけど
人が殴ろうとしてるんだったら
顔を合わせないようにしなさいよと
言った方がもう殴れませんですけどね
だから他の言葉でも言えることは言えますよ
人が自分のことを恨んで
もう殴ろうと企んでいると
では 堂々とそっちに行って
じゃあどうぞ殴ってくださいと
と言ってその問題解決しますかね
だからいくらでは堂々と言って殴ってもらいなさいということも言える
顔を合わせるなよということも言える
一回殴られたら逃げなさいよということも言えるし
だから殴ったら殴り返せっていうことは
良くない立場から見るとどちらでも言えますよ
だからこの心の法則は分かってないっていうことは明確なんですね
そちらで言っているのは
神は人間の罪を赦してるんだから
あなた方も互いの罪を赦しなさいよっていうぐらいのことなんですね
しかし 神は人間の罪を赦しているかないかっていうことは誰も知らないことなんですね
ただの信仰なんですね
そう思っているだけで
言い訳だけなんですね
だから 互いの罪を赦してあげることは
仲間同士では まあそうするしかないでしょうに
仲間同士で喧嘩が何かあったとしても
仲直りするしか方法ないでしょうに
ですから どんな家族をしたっても
どんな友達グループにしたっても
喧嘩もするし 喧嘩したらまた口きかないで
まあ 1週間  2週間ぐらいもいるし
また仲直りをする 仲直りしなきゃ
ずっと不幸でキリがないんですよ
夫婦喧嘩したっても もう口はきかないことにしたっても
二人ともそれが気になるんですね
気になって まあとにかくもう誰かがもう先に喋るまで待っているんですね
結局は そこで誰かが喋っちゃうと
もう何もなかったような感じで
もう喋り出すんですね
そういうことだから やっぱり一緒に生活しているグループでは仲直りするということはごく普通の当たり前のことなんですよ
だから聖書でもまあそこら辺ではないかなと思いますけどね
別にこの厳密に心の真理をね
でわかって言ってるわけじゃないんで
とにかく神が許したっていうことは成り立たないし
神がもう神を信仰する人
神に怯える人を許してあげるんであって
神を認めない人に対してどうするかというね
それはないでしょうに
神が完全な慈悲だったら
もう敵も誰もないんだからね
自分が作ったもんだからまとめて許してあげるでしょうに
そうすると 特別にイエス様いなくたってもね
特別にもういいことをしなくたってもね
神は許してくれるんだから
だからそこで崩れちゃいますね
理屈は そういうことだから
この偈はもうもうかなり有名な偈で
これは 覚えていない 暗記していない仏教徒っていうのは
まあいない ナヒヴェーレのヴェーラーニという経はね
暗記している人はいないほどのものなんですけど
まあまあだからといって
これは誰でも知っている一般論だと思ったら
それまた違います 一般論を言っているわけじゃない
これは真理知り尽くして言っていることなんです
そういうことで 大体この怒りという現れの
自分が何もしない 何も悪いことをしないで
自分の生き方をしていると
誰かが来て突然迷惑をかけちゃう
そうすると あんた何やってるんですか？ということを怒っちゃうんですね
なんで迷惑かけるんですかと
そこで怒りがスタートするんですよ
だから怒りのスタートはどこですかと
だから自分がもう何も悪いことをしていないのに
あの人はこんな言葉かけてきたんだと
あるいはこういうことをしましたと
そういうところで初めて怒りが生まれてくるんですね
だから怒りが生まれる先に自分が正しいというところがあるんですよ
だから どんな怒りの場合でも
自分が正しいという立場があって
そこから正しいなのに相手がやっていることは何なのかと
相手のことを考えた瞬間で
そこは怒りなんですね
まあ例えば瞑想しようとすると
この冷房の音がすごくうるさく聞こえる
うるさいな まあイライラするなと思ったら怒りですよ
その時も自分が静かなところにいたいんではないかと
なのになんだこの音はという態度なんですね
だから冷房の音は悪いんですよ
自分が正しいんですよ
そう思わない人には道路の側にでも瞑想できますよ
車が行くは 人は散歩するは
犬の散歩をするはとかね
オートバイはものすごい音を出して通るわとか
そんなことはもう何のことなく
バスなんか通っちゃうと
埃も自分の体にもぶつけてくるとかね
であっても 何のことなく落ち着いて瞑想できますよ
その場合は 私が瞑想しているんだから
なんだこの音 なんで人が行くんでしょう
なんで犬は来て自分のことをもう匂いも嗅いでみるんでしょうかとかと思っちゃうと怒りが出てくるでしょうね
そう思わない人は まあ私はこちらに座っているんだから
まあ車から埃が顔に当たるかもしれません
そんなのは当たり前やと
犬が来て自分の匂いを嗅いでみると
嗅いでみるだけじゃなくて
もしかしたらおしっこもかけるかもしれませんし
そこでボール遊びしている子供たちのボールが体に触れる
ぶつかる可能性もあるし
あるいはちょっとした悪ガキたちがいたら
もうこの人何やってるんでしょうかとかね
いろいろもう引っ張ったらいじめたりする可能性もあるし
だからそれはもう当たり前の当然のことではないかと思って座っている人にとっては
微かにでも怒りが生まれてこないんですよ
因果法則でわかっているんだから
この場所だったらこういう環境だよとちゃんと知っているんだったら
怒りが生まれてこないんですね
そういうところか もうちょっとでも蚊でも入ってきたら
もう苛立ちが なんだこれとかね
蚊には刺されるのは何ということかと
もう怒っているんですね
だから怒りが 自分が正しいというところからいつでも現れるもんなんです
時々人を騙そうと嘘をつく時もありますね
相手は騙されない時でも怒るんですよ
みんなもう相手をおだてたり
いろいろお世辞を言ったり
いろんなことをするでしょうに
それに乗らないと なんだあの人はとかね
それにも怒る このいろいろ宗教関与といろいろ商売とか
まあ来るともう まあおだてる
おだてる 全然それに乗らないと
もう怒るんですね 向こうが
ああ 大変お美しい奥様でと
なんとか言うと まあそれほどでもと言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
で そう言わないと あの人変な人で性格が悪いんですよと言うんです
そういう分勝手でしょうに
一生懸命こちら騙そうとしていて
騙されなかったらさえも怒るんだから
いつでも自分が正しいと
私はあなたを騙して言おうとするんだから
騙されなさいよという態度なんですよ
騙されるのは当たり前ではないかと
ですから いかなる場合でも自分が正しいと思うんだから
怒りが生まれてくるんですね
だから怒った時点でもう外れてますね
法則から 本当の真理知ってる人はいかなる場合でも怒らないんです
怒れないんですよ 真理知ってるんだったら
そういうわけで 仏教は微かな怒りでも
もうあなたもう脱線しちゃ
脱線したったということなんです
小さな怒りでも自分が正しいという
この なんとか まあその基盤から発生するもんなんです
どうやって自分が正しいと作れますかね？想定できますかね
それで この 自分が正しいところで怒りが出てくる
で それに向こうも怒ると
こちらの怒りがものすごくまた燃えちゃうんですね
もともとも正しいと思っている人に対して
もうさらに向こうが怒っちゃうと
もともとも正しいと怒っている人に対して
なんであんた怒るのと言ったら
またもうそこまであんた言葉まで言うつもりですかと
言い訳までするつもりですかということになるんですね
で どんどん怒りが燃えて燃えて燃えて燃えていくんです
[背景音楽]で それはすべての人間の生き方なんです
人間やらないのはやっぱりこの慈しみなんですね
誰もやらない慈しみがあるところに怒りがすぐ消えてしまうんですね
怒って成功するわけじゃないんですよ
人生はもう もう必ずも百パーセント失敗する
怒った場合は 不幸になる
もう決まっている だから一生懸命不幸な道を歩みながら
不幸になればなるほどさらに怒って
さらに不幸になる そうするとさらに怒るんですね
そのようになんかこの怒り
憎しみというものは続けて持っていくと
ただ それがこの綺麗にやめ
やめてみなさいと 自分の子供は交通事故で
まあ酒飲んで運転して
誰かにはめられて殺したならば
その人に対してずっと怒りを持つと
それは何の意味もないんですよ
そこで警察はもう手抜きで適当に調べようとしないで
その人は裁判で無罪になったと
無罪になって免許が戻ってきたと
また仕事をしているんだと
そんな話を聞いちゃうと
子供を殺された家族はどうなるんですかね
自分の子供を殺したなのに
その人は無罪になって
その上免許を戻っているんだと
結局不幸になるのはどちらですかね
で それで人間っていうのは
本当にもう不幸になることしか知らない
それで子供の写真の前で毎日泣いたり
誕生日にプレゼントを置いておいたりとかね
もうもう犬猫もしない
もうアホなことをずっとやっている
あるいは部屋そのまんまに置いておいたりとか
怒りを育てましょうと
悲しみ憎しみを育てましょうと
それで優しい被らも被っているんです
子供の愛する母親だから
子供のことを心配する父親だから
そうやってるんだと むちゃくちゃですよ
そんなの優しい子供のことを心配するということで
何でも死んだやつもう死んじゃったんだから
もうどうすることもできんでしょうに
それで自分たちも堂々と地獄に落ち行く
それで憎しみで もう憎しみでばっかしで燃えて燃えて
毎日写真を見て泣いたり
部屋をそのまんまにしておいたりして
誕生日になってくるとプレゼント買ってきて置いといたりしちゃうと
それであのお墓参りしたってもね
死んだ奴らがいいところに行けるんですかね
巨大な憎しみ 苦しみを与えたっても
だから回向にもなりませんし
供養にもなりません そんなの
もう残酷ですよ 過去生で何か不幸が不幸なことをして
その後で子供は自分の運命を持ってるんだから死んじゃったでしょうに
死んじゃったらとんでもない親のところで生まれたせいで
それから供養するという形でどんどん不幸
さらに悪業を回向してもらう
そこで死んだ霊にも知識がないならば
私の親が一生懸命やってくるんだとそれで喜んじゃうと
悪を受けたことになるんです
だから そんなのキリがない
ものすごい不幸なやり方になっちゃうんですね
だからこの仏教は残酷やとも言う人もいますけど
そういう人々は怒りに狂ってるだけのことで
仏教はものすごい慈しみなんです
子供がもう誰かに殺されたって
まああいつのなんか過去で悪いことしたんじゃないんですか？とかね
そう思うんですよ 突然そうやって殺されちゃったんだから
親は悩むんだけど その時はもう一生懸命良いことをして
徳を移行してあげるんですね
これからでもそうやって不幸に短命にならないようにとかね
殺した人を憎いとかね
殺してやりたいとかね
そういうことはないんですよ
とにかく殺しの場合はそういうことで
また 子供を守る場合はまた別なことで
生きてる子供を誰かに殴られそうになっちゃうと
その人を殴ってでも自分の子供を守る
それはまたまるっきり別な話で
自分の子供を誰か殴られると
こいつは過去世で何か悪い業をしたのではないかとか思ってじっと待っていると
それはもういい加減なことでね
そこそこ不幸に出会ってもあまり気にしないというのは
この初期仏教的な立場なんですね
何か原因があるんだよと
原因なしには起こるはずがないんだと
ですから 仏教の世界で誰が気にするもんかと
そんなのはという態度で生きているんです
で どんどん一生懸命良いことをする
良いことをしてもしても運命が変わらないんだったら
それも気にしない 自分の業がそう簡単には消えるものじゃないみたいみたいですよと
それでも良いことだけする
それだけでも世界は良くなりますからね
みんな良いことしか知らない
しない場合はもう業が消えますよ
殺される業がある人でも
良いことしかしない社会で生まれたら殺されませんだから
誰も殺しませんだから
それでも業が深いんだったら
崖に落ちて落ちて死んだとかね
そういうことはあり得るかもしれませんだけど
その時は誰に対しても憎しみも恨みもないでしょうに
事故で死んじゃったということになるんだから
ですから とにかく良いことをするということは
仏教的な立場で で わずかにでもかすかにでも怒るということは自分が間違いなんです
そこでエーサダンモーサなんてのは
この真理はもう永遠の真理であると
永遠の真理であると言っているんですから
これは心の法則であるということなんですね
だからまあ これはどうにもならないことで
過去であろうと現在であろうと将来であろうと
心の法則はこの法則なんです
うん それは今日は一つだけにしたいんですけど
まあとにかくこの偈を覚えておいてください
先生 瞑想して悟りを開くことができるのは人間だけだと思っていたので
生きとし生けるものが
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますようにという
その瞑想の実践をですね
その生きとし生けるものがやがて人間に生まれ変わって
それは悟りを開きますようにという意味で唱えていたんですけども
そうじゃなくても その状態からも悟りに行けるというふうに
今日のお話を伺ってと思いましたので
それでよろしいでしょうか
だからそれでよろしいじゃない
なんでそんなに慈悲の瞑想にケチるんですかね
何か言い訳がないとできんという状態でしょう
言ってるの  そうじゃなくてですね
一回人間に生まれてきて
なんでそこまで心配するんですかね
そういう意味ではちょっと勘違いしてたなと
今日のお話伺って思います
それはちょっとなんか考えすぎですよ
だから自分の慈悲がちゃんと機能しないともったいないとか
それをケチってるってことなんですよ
ケチるっていうことは
慈悲を与えたくないっていうことなんですよ
だから自分の心が自分を騙してるんです
それで本当の慈悲がもう成り立たなくなっちゃうんですよ
心っていうのはものすごく騙すんです
自分にとってはいいこと考えてるつもりなんです
全ての生は人間になって
一旦それから悟ってほしいやとかね
そこまで自分の責任じゃないんだからね
この 5番目の偈のところ
これは永遠の真理であるっていうことは
2つのことを言ってると思うんで
それは恨みで恨みに対して恨みを持つっていうのは
これは普通の心の状態ですよね
普通の人間の だから恨みで返せばそうなるよっていうのが
仏教以外の全ての人々はそう思ってて
日本でも決心ぐらが流行るみたいに
恨みで返すのがいいみたいに思ってるわけなんですよ
仏教ではこういうことを言ってるんですけど
恨みを捨てるっていうことは
僕は今悟らないとできないんじゃないかと思ったんですけど
今彼の質問でね 慈悲の心を持てばできるのかなと
別に悟らなくても恨みを捨てることはできるかなっていう
できるに なかなか非常に難しいことだけど
できるのかしらっていう
できるんだからお釈迦様おっしゃってるんであってね
できないものを言ったって意味がないしね
仏教ではできないことは一つも言ってないんですよ
できないことを言ってもね
水の中に生活しなさいとかね
でも悟りを 恨みを捨てなさいっていうことは結構難しいことのように
難しいのは頭が悪いんだからなんですね
だから人間というのは法則
因果法則は考えない 論理的じゃない
感情で わがままで 何かを言う
何かを思うということでしょうね
世の中はね そういうふうに無知でいいわけじゃないでしょうに
もうちょっとしっかりしてほしい
してほしいし だから恨みをなくすということでも
しっかりしなきゃできるものじゃないんですよ
もう芯もなくて ぐにゃぐにゃ性格で
もう誘惑されやすくて
乗りやすくて そういうタイプのね
生き方ではね それは仏教が認めている生き方ではないしね
ですから恨みを捨てるということは
それはもう難しいかもしれませんけど
やりなさいということなんです
いちいちごちゃごちゃ言うなよと
恨み捨てなさいよと それくらい勇気を出してほしいんですよ
言われたら正しいことだから
はい 分かります やりますと
正しいことを言ってるんだからね
正しいんだけど やりたくないんだと言ったら
だったら勝手にしなさいということになっちゃうの
ですから やっぱりまあ悟らないとできんということも弱み言ってるんですよ
だから心に騙されては
騙されてはいけませんよ
例えば普通そういう思考がぼんぼん出てきますよ
あれ悟らなきゃ無理でしょうとかって言った途端
もう自分がもうしなくてっていう
しないことに言い訳は結べているんですね
ですから そういう道徳っていうのは
もう悟るまで待つもんじゃないんですよ
今すぐやらなくちゃいかんことなんです
難しさはちゃんとあるんです
一人も真理の世界ではなくて
幻覚の中にいるんだから
もう真理のまね事でも難しいんですよ
例えば 鏡の部屋の中に猿を入れちゃったら
もう猿のどこ見たって猿ばっかし見えちゃうと
驚いたり混乱したりする
その猿にはこれは鏡だよと理解して
じゃあ落ち着けばいいやということにはちょっと難しいんですよ
難しいんだけど 鏡の部屋の猿はもう鏡ぶつけてぶつけて
噛んだり噛んだりしちゃうと
自分が怪我して苦しむだけなんですね
相手を威嚇しよう威嚇すると思っちゃうと
向こうも威嚇するんだからキリがなくなっちゃうんです
だから鏡を破っちゃえば簡単なんですけど
まあそこまで怒ってやるぞと思っちゃう
どうなるんですかね 誰かが私を鏡の部屋から普通の檻に入れるまで
私は踏ん張って攻撃するぞと
いて猿がもうそういう神様がいないんだからね
人生には 猿にはいるかもしれませんだけど
ですから 怒りなくすということは
もう当然怒らないでいるということは
かなり精神力が必要なんですね
だからそれを言い訳にしちゃうとどうにもならない
その精神力を育てることは仏教なんです
怒らないでいられると
相手がザンザン悪いことしているのに
自分が慈しみで返しているんだと
相手は邪魔しか何もしないのに
自分ができるところですぐ助けてあげると
助け求める瞬間ですぐ助けてあげると
何にも言い訳もしないで
それはかなりの人格がないとできないもので
だからやることで人格が出てくるんです
総合的に このしっかりした人格者になるということは
これはもう大変な必要なことで
ただ生ぬるく怒らないようにニコニコしただけでも効き目がないんです
私は怒りませんよとか何とかでね
そういう態度もあまり意味がないし
怒らないということをしっかりするんですね
そうすると芯が強い人間にはなります
この芯が強い人間というのは
相手を潰すための芯が強いという意味ではないんですね
私たちも芯の強い人間がいいなと思うのは
その対立を潰すためなんです
他人に貸すためなんです
それまた怒りなんです
だから心は常に自分が正しいと思っている
だから怒るっていうことは
ものすごい普通 当然な普通なことなんです
自分が正しいというその土台が
仏教はもう粉々に壊すんですよ
勝手に思っているだけではないかと
自我はないんではないかと
だからそこまでいく人々っていうのは
数は少ないんですけどね
人間から見ると だからって世の中苦しんでいいんでしょうかね
このままで戦争起きたり
もう大量殺人やら殺戮が起きたり
人類破滅になったり もうどう頑張っても不幸しかなくて
泣きながら苦労しながら
そんな生き方でいいんでしょうかと
だから恨まないというたった一言葉
それだけでも世の中に通じるならば
それだけでほとんどの問題が消えていくんですよ
だからブッダの言葉の強さっていうのは
たくさん勉強しなくても
たった一つの言葉を見ても完全に語ってます
人類の問題には完全な答えそちらにあるんです
どんな一言葉を見ても
だから仏教はこの思想的にリストアップして
それ難しいのはそういうポイントなんです
みんな仏教ってこういうものだと
ちゃんと順番かけて １ ２ ３ ４
まだこれとこれとこれと
そうは言えません 一言葉でも一言葉でも完全に全て喋っているんです
ですから 一応我々は あの
何と言いますか あのシステムですね
あの思想体系みたいに思想体系化しようとはするんですけど
その体系っていうのはそんなにきついものじゃないんですよ
すぐ潰れちゃいます まず仏教は戒律を守ることやら
いいことをすることを教えているんだよ
それからちょっとちょっと良いことをする
それから瞑想することを教えてるんだよとかね
まあそれから順番で悟るということを言ってるんだよとかね
それは順番で全部やらなくちゃいけない
それはないんですよ 戒律一つ
一言見たって そこで全部書いて語ってるんです
そういうことで この一個一個のブッダの言葉も全て完璧な教えで
もう欠けてないんです
何かを 我々から見れば
これ怒りしか扱ってないんだよという風には見え
当然そうなんです で 怒りという現象から心の法則見えるはずなんです
それで人間が歩むべき道が見えるはずなんです
人間が歩むべき道を歩むならば
人間にある全ての問題は解決するはずなんです
そういうわけで ブッダの言葉っていうのは
もう世界で人類に誰にも語れない完璧な言葉だと言っているんです
訂正もできない 私はイエス様の言葉にいろいろ文句言ったんですけど
これにはどう頑張っても何も言えませんよ
反論は成り立ちません
それで世の中でどんな論にも反論成り立ちます
どんなテーゼにもアンチテーゼというのはもう世の中ではあるんですよ
長いと言ったら短いというものはもうそちらにあるんだからね
それで人間の言葉でテーゼだけ作ってアンチテーゼはないと
できればそういう言葉を作ってみてください
人間作るどんな言葉でも一つ作ったら
すぐアンチテーゼが成り立つんです
ちょっとケチをつけるところはどうしても出てくるんです
そこまで気をつけて語っているところなんですね
崩れるのは我々自分の主観で解釈しようとするんですよ
まあ例えば  まあそれは分かりますよと
恨みは恨みでは消えませんと
しかしですね 何も悪いことをしていない人に散々いじめられると
一言葉やってあげないと
一つ言ってあげないと
もうキリがないではないんでしょうかと言うんでしょ
それは自分の主観であって
あるいは人を諭すために怒ることは悪くないんではないんでしょうかとかね
そんなのはいい加減な言葉なんですよ
だから人間が自分の主観で解釈しようとすると崩れますよ
自分の主観で解釈しないで
ちゃんと正しい解釈をすると
アンチテーゼは成り立たないということは見えてくるんです
だから正当防衛っていうのは成り立たないんです
防衛は成り立ちますけど
世の中みんな善人ではないんだから
自分たちを殺そうしている人々はいくらでもいるかもしれません
しかし その人を殺してはいいわけじゃないんです
自分を守ればいいんです
仏教がというのは 誰かが狙って自分を殺そうしているんだったら
やっぱり頑張ってでもその人に慈悲を実践する
100回  200回  1億回断られてもやってみなさいよと
それでもその人の憎しみが消えなくても
君は成功しているんだと
だから損はしない 誰が自分を狙って殺そうとしている人だったら
その人のいろんな方法を取って
いろんなことをその人を助けてあげたり
心配してあげたり いろんなことをしてあげていると
やがてその人の心にはその怒りは必ずしも消える
例えば 怒っている人に病気になっていると
毎日弁当を持って行っても全部捨てられるんだと
あなたのもの食べませんよと
その人は怒られているんだから
それでまた次の日 また次の日もとかね
全部捨てられたってもいいんですよ
それで その場合はっきりしているんだから
性格は直らないのはどちらかと
だからってその人を攻撃する必要はないんでしょうに
やっぱりあの人はなかなかもう仲直りはしない
頑固でいたいみたいですよと
仲直りにしないで憎しみでいると
その人は苦しいでしょうと
でも私は私なりに一生懸命頑張りましたと
しかし直らない では諦めましょうということで諦めればいいんです
諦めて自分が慈しみを持っている
それでも苦しんで欲しくないと
私の世の人間だったら
堂々とあなたに怒られても
私には屁でも何でもないんだよと
でもあなた苦しんでいるのを見ていられないんだから来たんだよと
そんなに楽しいんだったら堂々やってくださいと
憎しむことは あんたそれですごく不幸になってかっこいいと思ったんだったら
堂々とやってくださいと
あなたに怒られたって
あなたに仲良くしてくれても
私にとって迷惑だけですよと言って帰っちゃうんです
それでその人はもう治ると思いますよ
だからこの まあ顔も知らない
もうもうもう何も もう知らない誰かにね
自分が全くもう想像 そうもしないところで誰かに殺されたりしちゃうと
まあそれでもその人は別に狙ったわけでもないし
まあその時でもやっぱり憎しむことって見えないんですね
憎しむ原因というのは
例えば野球とかね まあサッカーとか見に行ったところで
まあ何か混乱起きちゃって
まあみんなお互いにまあ振ったり蹴ったりって言って
いろいろなことが起きちゃって
自分が踏み潰されちゃって死んじゃったと
踏み潰された この連中は何者かという
なんで怒るんですかね
その時でもやっぱりまあそんなしょうがないことだからね
みんな意図的にやってるものではないんだから
大変だ 私はまあ怒っちゃったんだから
みんなにもふすますらって
ということでも そのまま死ねばいいっていうことなんですよ
死ぬ時はすぐすぐ死んじゃいます
死んじゃいますからね
人が狙って自分を狙って
もう何かあるんだったら
自分にも原因があるでしょうに
必ず その場合は仲直りするように
もう頑張るしかない うん
まああの 悟らなくてもやらなくてはいけないんです
で 悟るまで怒るんだったら永久に悟れません
悟る過程はちゃんと人格を作る過程だから
それはもう飛ぶことはできません
怒るは欲張るはわがままでいい加減で
性格はそのままですぐ早く悟りたいとかね
それはありえません だからなぜ瞑想は上手くいかないかということでも
そちらすごい原因があるんですね
よくよくチェックするんだけど
理性的にはなりたくない
絶対なってやらないぞという覚悟を決めています
自分の性格は正しいんだから
ガチャガチャ言うなよという態度をとってます
みんな 私は私なりにこういう風に生きてきたんだからという態度では
もういくら瞑想したってもう全然成長しない
それで瞑想して 一発で全部OKにしてやるぞと
私の性格はそのままで
悟ったら気楽に全部うまくいくぞと
そういう新宗教の話ではありません
ですから やっぱり難しいなのに怒らないことは実践しなくちゃいけない
難しいなのに欲張らないことは実践しなくちゃいけない
難しいなのに嘘をつかないということは実践しなくちゃいけない
難しいのに無駄話はしないと実践しなくちゃいけない
難しいなのに悪口は言わないと実践しなくちゃいけないんです
それで性格がゆっくりゆっくりと変わっていく
人がどんどん変わっていく
すごい芯の強い人間になる
それで最後に なんでこんなにいいことをするために
そんなに大変でしょうかと自己観察すれば法則が見えてくる
それで終わります 簡単に
だから法則をこのシステム見えたら
その人はもう悟りに瞬時に至るんだからね
怒るのは当たり前よ 態度ではもう何百年頑張ったってももうダメなんですよ
ではなくて 怒るのは絶対ダメ
全く間違っている 絶対怒りたくない
なのに大変だ これ怒らないでいるということはとという人が怒らないでいるならば
怒らないでいる 絶対怒りたくない
怒りは全く間違っている
もう知っている そこまで知っている
なんでこんなに大変だなと自己観察したら
もうそちらに悟りがあるんです
ああ こういうわけかと
それで見えますから そういうことだから
やっぱりこのお釈迦様おっしゃっている道は悟るまで待つんじゃなくて
歩む道 道なんですね よく覚えてほしいのは
悟った人にした説法は一つもないんです
すべての説法は悟ってない人に言ってるんです
悟った人には何も説法はなし
だからその論理は大体は成り立たないんです
これが実践できるのは悟った人ですよと言っちゃっても
何の意味もないんです
だからなんで悟った人に説法するんですかね
全くも怒りない人に あんた知ってますかね？恨みは恨みで消えませんよ
何の意味もないでしょうね
だからお釈迦様は悟った人には説法しません
日本の仏教でよく忍耐という言葉が出てくるんですけど
テーラワーダの話を聞いてますと
そういう言葉が全然出てこなくてですね
見方が全然違うなというふうに思うんですけども
忍耐ありますよ カンテという言葉は
全くというとちょっと違うんですけども
そういうものを忍耐として捉えないといいますか
そういうふうに聞こえるんですか
自分を観察して冷静に見ていくという
何か無理やり自分を抑えつけて我慢しているという
そういう忍耐じゃないのか
そういう意味の忍耐っていうのは無理するって意味なんですよ
無理するっていう意味は自分が正しいんですけど
まああんた言うんだからやりますという態度なんですよ
いわゆる怒る自分が正しいんだけど
怒るなよっていうのだったら
じゃあ頑張って怒らないようにするぞと
しかし怒りたいよと それはもう今おっしゃってる忍耐の定義なんですね
それはもう悪だからね
だから我慢するという言葉はもう間違えてますね
我慢するんじゃなくて
それは事実だからやるんですよ
やるのは大変だよという方が
仏教でいうカンテですね
忍耐なんですね 大変であることは当たり前だからね
でも我慢する必要ないんですよ
注射打つ場合は痛いんですけど
我慢するってもう当たり前だからね
その時忍耐をする 怒りがないんです
痛い痛い痛い痛いと もう泣くかもしれませんだけど
その泣きも明るいんですよ
ですから この俗世間でいう大乗仏教ではどう言ってるかって
また別なんですけど わからないんですけど
俗世間でいう忍耐ではないんですね
俗世間でいうっていうのは
もうただ 自分の意思に反して自分が正しいなのに世間言うことをやる場合なんです
それはいくらやったっても人は成長しません
ですから カンテっていうのは仏教ではもう必ずもあることで
それはもうずっとあるんであって
別の言い方すると サティがしっかりできている人は怒ることもありえない
ですから よくサティができていると
そういうふうに言えるわけですよね
だからよくサティをできるようにすることも大変ですよ
どちらでも大変です 簡単じゃないんです
心ができて そういう風にできているんだから
悪い方に行くように 苦労に苦しみになるように心ができているんだから
その間違い直すっていうことは
どんな角度から見ても大変
楽ではありません 道は楽ではありませんということで
ちょっと頑張りなさいということになるんですね
腰を上げるなよと すぐ腰上げちゃうと何もに達しませんよと
だから嫌な忍耐と楽しみ忍耐が 2つありますからね
良い境地をね 目指して頑張ることは嫌じゃないでしょうに
とにかく嫌々やるという人はもう早く終わりたいという気持ちでやってますからね
その人にとってそれは苦しいんですね
4キロは歩くと 一人がなんで歩く？なんで車がないんですか？とか
なんで自転車でもないんですか？とかね
ぐーぐーと文句言って歩く人にとっては
それは苦しいんです では散歩をする
そうと 4キロも どれぐらいできるでしょうかとかね
何分でできるでしょうかと
ということで 歩く人にとってはすごく楽しいことなんですね
やっぱり 4キロになってくると結構疲れるもんだなとかね
その人楽しく言うんですよ
ですから この それで悪い忍耐と正しい忍耐っていうのは
まあ理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
良いことを目指して頑張るっていうことなんですね
では  ここら辺で終了いたします
何か他の質問ございますか？はい
皆さんに悪いから個人的に聞こうと思ったんですけど
あの 普通歩行禅と座禅があの朝やってるんですけれども
あの歩行禅の方は割とあの自分では
あの 自分の動きっていうのを確認しやすいんですけど
座禅の方ではですね あの呼吸のあの膨らみ縮みっていうのを
あの確認はしてる時はしてるんですけど
他にあの痛みだとか音とかっていうのを
あの違う対象に向けてしまうと
なんかこうそのままそのラベリングっていうか
えーと 実況中継ができなくなってしまう傾向があるんですけど
そういう時は  で いつの間にかラベリングしないまま
例えば 1時間とか終わっちゃうっていうような場合が結構あるんですけど
そういう時はどうしたらいいんでしょう？で
一つの対策としてあのやってみたのは
あの座禅してる時も その他の対象はほとんどもう無視して
いつもあの膨らみ縮みっていうのだけを
あの に注意を向けてラベリングするっていうこともやってみました
その時はまあ大体はうまくいくんですけど
それだと あの 長老のおっしゃっている
あの座禅のやり方と違うのかなっていう
そういうことが気になりましたので
相談したいと  で あの やった方法ではいいとは思います
まずはあの じゃあ膨らみ縮みだけ見てみるんだと
それでそれだけじっと見てみる
で 見てみると間では自分には気づかないで心が結構あっちこっち行くんですよ
それはわかります  そこを管理する
そこを管理する いろんなところに行く心を
いえ こちら こちらに絞ってもらうぞと
あっちこっち行くんだけど
自分が膨らみ縮みに決めたんだから
膨らみ縮みだけやってますけど
それが弱いんですね サティが
いろんなところに走ってるんだからね
だから走るたびに確認すると
本当にあのサティが強いんですけど
まあこれでちょっと自分にとってはうまくいかないなと思っちゃうと
一つに決めてもいいんです
一つに決めても 本当に一つだけやってるんでしょうかと自分を疑ってチェックするんです
そうすると心がなんかいろんな枝分かれで
いろんなところをちらちらと知りながら膨らみ縮みやってるってこと見えてくるんですね
それはよくわかるんですけど
まあ本当は一つ一つ動いていったのがサティができれば
あの なるようにした方がいいっていうことだけどっていうことですか？とりあえずはそういう
その きちっと膨らみ縮みを管理できるように
そういうことでも そういうことでしています
お供えのことなんですが
お供えはお釈迦様にお供えあげたものを下げていただくということはするのですか
まあそれはね そんなに厳しくは考えてないんですけどね
私たちの場合はまた後で食べてもらう気持ちではあげませんね
これはお布施ですから
お釈迦様に対する まあちょっと今あげて
後で自分で取って食べるぞというのもあげたことになりませんだからね
まあ日本ではもう自分で食べる欲がそのままで
全部仏壇にお供えして
それからもう欲張って食べるんですけど
お供えにはなりませんね
なりませんでしたも それも一つの習慣ですからね
まあそれはそれでよろしいんですけど
やっぱりお釈迦様にお食事やらお飲み物は
ちゃんとお釈迦様生きていた時と同じく
まあ差し上げる 人にご飯をあげて
またそれは返してちょうだいと
私が食べますということは
ちょっと 良くないんですね
そこでお供えを下げて処分する場合は
これどうしましょうかということもまた別の話で
処分する過程で食べてもいいんじゃないかということで
みんなで食べちゃってもね
あげる時は決して後で食べるつもりではあげません
注釈書では まあそれはまあ
例えば仏像とか そのお寺とか
そちら辺できちんと管理して
掃除 掃除 洗濯する何から何までね
このお寺の管理はしている人が取って食べてもよろしいと
でもそれを食べる前に
その寺の木までいっぱいたくさんありますから
それは全部その人はやらなくてはいけないんだと
お釈迦様のお世話する場合は
あの人間のお世話をするときでも
そのお世話する人での食べ残しやらね
残ったものやら 食べるのはお世話係は食べるのは当たり前
普通のことやと そういう感じにならなくてはいけないんだと
出家の場合はもう時間の問題もありますから
後で掃除終わってお世話終わって食べようと思ったら 3時ぐらいになるかもしれません
そういう場合は先に食べても構いませんと
でも食べてから全部自分でお世話をしなくちゃいけないというふうには書いてますけどね
はっきりはしていないんですけどね
とにかく我々はもう一応もうお釈迦様にあげたものには手を出しません
では どうもありがとうございます
サンパティ [silence]